hello everyone we have another very
exciting game from round 10 of the tata
steel chess tournament where Carlsen
seems to have employed the Magnus effect
once again now I've seen a lot of games
where the London system has been used as
consummated so popular seems like
everyone is playing the London system
nowadays but I've never actually seen it
played quite like this so let's see this
game and it has quite a lot of
interesting interesting moments Carson
has the white pieces and he opens up
with f3 Wesley plays d5 we have d4
Knight to f6 and Bishop to f4 going for
the long system we have Bishop to f5 by
Wesley III and now II 6 and if you look
at this standard setup for the London
system by Carlsen it seems Wesley
employs the the exact same setup with
the black pieces so it seems like
Wesley's countering the London system
would a London system of his own I'm
sure this is perfectly fine I just I've
just never seen black counter the London
system with this so c4 by Carson and we
have Bishop captures on b1 and already
some interesting choices to be made here
now you do have the option of capturing
it with the rook you do have the option
of capturing with the Queen
the problem with capturing with the rook
is this Bishop to b4 check and now as
your queen is on d1 you have to play
King - E - you can't block with the
night because if tonight's the e4 there
is no way to to unpin you're losing a
piece here there is one way that is
Queen to a4 check but after knight c6
blocking and defending the Bushman
before now you have to play rook to d1
and black can simply choose whether it
will whether he will win the exchange
immediately after Bishop captures and e2
with check or he will simply cancel and
after whatever white plays simply
continue attacking and at any point
black can win when the exchange here and
he will be simply better and probably
winning
so after this Bishop capture some b1
across some plays a clean capture some
b1 we have Bishop to b4 checked and now
came to d1
Bushra back to d6 as this bishop
did his work there on before and Bishop
to g5 an opening the night h6 and Bishop
captures on f6 Queen captures and seek
address on d5 each chapters on d5 and
here we have e 4 and now Carson is
threatening to push a 5 attacking the
Queen and the bishop here and you can't
really capture it after Queen captures
on e4 here this comes with 2 check and
then attack on the b7 pawn so after you
block this let's say bitter to e7
Carlsen can simply capture and it's a
winning position for white so after this
efore move we have Bishop to e7
and now Carlsen definitely does want to
push a e5 but he doesn't want to do it
immediately if he doesn't immediately
then black has the option of going Queen
to b6 and after the knight is developed
on c6 there will be some substantial
pressure on the d4 pawn and also the b2
point will be harassed so instead after
this Bishop to e7 crossing goes for
Bishop to b5 check and you don't really
have any options here other than pushing
c6 if you play Knight to d7 simply
Bishop captures and King has to move if
you play Knight to c6 then after ecaps
or Sun on d5 you lose a piece here and
there's really really not a lot to do
here ok you don't lose a piece you can
counter it with a 6 but still after D
captures Bishop capped pawn captures
Bishop and you cap from b7 again it's a
much better position for white you have
to react it this white will castle not
castle but to bring the rook into the
game so it's a better position for white
so after this Bishop to b5 check Wesley
doesn't go for this he goes for c6 and
only now before retreating with the
Bishop e5 is played so Queen to f4
now that the c6 has been played there is
no more Queen to b6 option so Queen to
f4 would have Bishop to d3 and now c5 d
captures on c5 Knight to c6 and Queen to
c1 by Carlson Carlson
not allowing Wesley to capture the pawn
on e5 so Queen to b4 the climbing
the trade of Queens we have a three and
now capturing upon win captures we have
king to eat to now connecting the rook
and the Queen so this route can also
come into the game and you don't really
want you don't really want to exchange
Queens here or maybe maybe you can go
for something like Queen to b6 but the
Wesley decides to go for Knight to the
d4 check we have nice capture screen
captures and now F for Wesley castles
and we have Queen to d2 now Carson has a
threat of Bishop to h7 check picking up
the queen on d4 so Queen to b6 now and
rook H 2 e 1 we have f6 and this is a
very interesting moment in the game as
this this gives the cousin the
opportunity to play one very interesting
move which he plays after this f6 move
probably this wasn't the best idea
probably best was to simply bring your
rooks into the game Leah e or D file but
what's the place f6 he wants to open up
the position as crossings King is
somewhat awkwardly placed on e2 but here
Carlsen instead he doesn't want to open
up the position he plays ecigs and this
is a very interesting moment what do you
do here probably the best thing for
Wesley is to push f5 to nullify the
influence of this bishop on d3 but he
decides to capture upon Queen captures
and we have kink to f3 now opening up a
discovered attack from the roof to the
Queen Queen has to move but also keep
protecting the bishop on e7 so Queen to
d7 and now rook a to d1 and broke a to
d8 and if you look at this position
Carlson has a king on f3 which seems to
be the bit awkward but his position is
actually completely fine
he can play Bishop to c4 immediately win
the pawn back but he doesn't he doesn't
want to go for this he has the white
pieces and he has to catch up to the
leading players of the tournament
so one other thing look at look at the
Wesley's bone structure around the King
and he has a dark square bishop so
there's really not much this Bishop
contood
do to help out with the defense it'd be
much better if the pawns were on light
squares but okay and Carson's bishop is
very active on this long light square
diagonal so Queen e2 e3 and does
constant doesn't go for Bishop to c4 he
doesn't one I want to win the material
back immediately threatening to capture
the bishop on e7 Bishop to d6 and now
Bishop to g6 and you probably might want
to check out the idea of Bishop to b1 as
the light squares are extremely weak
around blacks King and there could be
some Queen to d3 threats going for
checkmate but here black would actually
just push g5 and then it would get very
dangerous for Carlsen as the position
would now open up and his King is still
awkwardly placed on III and Queen to b3
doesn't really do anything now since the
Queen is covering the entire 7th rank so
after Bishop to b6 Carson goes for the
most more human-like move Bishop to g6
and now completely not allowing the
scheme to move anywhere from the back
rank and also not allowing the rook to
ever come to e8 so this is definitely
the way to go
we had f5 and here cousin goes for Queen
to e6 check offering a trade of Queen's
Queen captures rook captures and Bishop
to c5 we have roughly 5 threatening to
win the pawn here attacking both the f5
pawn and d5 pawn and we have looked to
f6 now attacking the bishop on g6 and
it's it's hard to say can cross and
capture this pawn well he does capture
it Bishop captures and now we have
Bishop to d6 and this is probably what
Wesley saw Wesley saw rook eek after 75
and here g6
this bishop would have to move Bishop to
c2 and now rook captures on f4 would
check King to g3 and now rook to d4
check opening up a discovered attack
from the bishop you can't capture it
because you just lose the exchange so
probably something like into H 3 and
then comes rook captures on d5 rod
capture 75 and if you look at this
position two points each on the
seven on the queenside opposite colored
bishops this is a completely drawing
position but after this Bishop to d6
move instead of rook he captures on d5
across in place rook D captures on d5
and now it's it's not all that clear now
g6 doesn't really achieve anything if
you fry g6 now you simply get Bishop to
e6 check King has to move and now rook
to e4
you're defending f4 you just wanna pawn
you know for nothing so after this rook
D captures on b5 Wesley try King to f7
but now simply rook to e4 and again
everything is defended so Carson just
snatched a pawn here g6 we have Bishop
to g4 and h5 Bishop to h3 and rook to e8
and what do you do here you can you can
definitely capture the rook the rook
captures on e8 and King will have to
recapture so it's a fine move for
Carlsen but Carson doesn't want to allow
this position where one one pair of
Brooks has been traded and there are
opposite color bishops on the board as
this would be more easily drawn you
don't have any rook captures on a for
ideas for black here like using that as
an in-between move because after King
III Black has just lost I mean you have
to recapture the rookie now your bishop
is hanging so after rook to e8 cross in
place rook e to d4 we have Bishop to e5
rook to b5 now attacking the pawn on b7
and here Wesley plays g5 and again a
very interesting position
Wesley offers Carson to grab the b7 pawn
and the interesting thing is Carson
declines this it's it's a very
complicated variation if you capture it
you have to you have to play something
like King to f8 and now your F pawn here
is attacked three times but a bishop
rook and by the G pawn and you don't
have time to play g3 and to bring the
Ruby back to be 4 so here probably g3
would have to be played and here Wesley
would have a lot of options one of them
would be actually to play Bishop
captures on f4 and that maybe even after
she captures rook captures and here it's
it's a force to draw so instead after
this g5 move Carlson doesn't capture he
plays g3 and here we have b6 now notice
that Wesley can always push this g4 and
win a bishop but he will have to give up
these two points and this is something
where Wesley is very reluctant to do so
here we have b6 defending the b7 pawn
now and here cross in place rook to e7
check King to f8 was played if you block
with the rock you lose the game
immediately rock capture screen captures
and now rook to e4 pinning the bishop so
you'd probably have to play g4 Bishop
captures H capture skin captures your
bishop is still pinned and there's
really nothing you can do here after
rook moves simply capture it and you
have three extra points this is a
completely winning position
so after this rook to d7 move Wesley
plays King to f8 and here we have row to
h7 it's interesting I have no idea why
Carlson didn't capture the a7 point as
it doesn't seem to change anything
instead of capturing this and having one
extra pawn across and actually plays
rook to h7 going for the h h5 point here
and this basically forces Wesley to push
g4 so this is what Carlson was going for
probably
g4 h Bishop captures H captures and King
captures and G for your bishop is still
attached to Bishop to d6 attacking the
rook rook to c4 and a5 now so I don't
know I think it'd be better if he
grabbed the DF D a pawn but probably he
had something else in mind
maybe this kind of forces this roof to
stay there as there are some threats of
hope to see it but I'm sure I'm sure he
saw something so if you look at the
position now crocin has three connected
passed pawns for the bishop and it
doesn't matter what the evaluation of
this position is as a human you prefer
three connected passed pawns to a to a
bishop
so wrote the c6 attacking the b6 pawn
and here we have King to g8 attacking
the rook rook goes back to b7 now again
attacking the b6 pawn and here we have
Bishop to e5 opening up at the
discovered attack from the roof to the
rook and here across some place rook
captures on b6 rook captures and rook
captures so now Carlson has four points
for the Bishop Bishop to d4 attacking
the rook rook to b5 and rook to e2 we
have b3 rook captures on h2 and now rook
captures on a five so now Carlson has
four connected I mean to two points here
are connected and to hero connected
passed pawns for the bishop so this is a
I mean maybe it would like insane alpha0
play you could draw this with black but
the human against the human not very
likely rook to e2 we have worked to d5
Bishop goes to B to a for Bishop to c3
stopping the pawns on the dark squares
came to a5 rook to e8 we have g4 now
wrote to f8 King to e4 rook to b8
attacking the pawn rook blocks and a
very interesting position you have to
know that if rook captures then white is
winning why is white winning well I just
see real quickly if ro captures a
captures then the there are pawns on
both sides of the board and the bishop
and King cannot stop them we have here
for example stopping the pawn but now
King comes closer to help the pawn king
f7 let's say King c6 preparing b6 now
King g7 b6 bishop has to move
we have f5 now now the bones and the
other side of the board starts marching
forward but the c3 now b7 Bishop to e5
stopping b8 but now the G pawn is coming
Bishop to f4 King b6 now going for King
to a7 to promote the pawn so Bishop to
be 8 and now oh all the pawn starts
marching forward
g6 King goes back g7 can go CR f6 you
can't capture because the G pawn is
promoting King g8 now the king comes to
help out the pawns on the King side came
here King here some some some piece has
to move if if you move the King then
King to e8 and then this pawn is coming
going to become a queen so Bishop to f4
now Queen King captures and this was a
upon sacrifice simply to deflect the
King now there are simply too many
threats King h7 f 7 and after Bishop
here the bishop cannot stop both bones
you simply sacrifice another one and
then promote the other one to a queen so
this is just a quick example why you
can't do this so rook to e8 check by
Wesley we have King d3 the ship to d1
now the a pawn comes up Bishop - f - B
for rook to e3 check King C for rook
checks here King 2 B 3 and again
interesting why couldn't you capture the
F for pawn if you capture the pawn you
get a rope to a5 and now you have to
trade rooks and again the to passed
pawns are too powerful for the bishop to
stop and you can't move the rug because
the bishop on f2 is hanging
so after this team to b3 came to f7 now
now crossing goes for a rope to d5
again for trying to get Wesley to
capture the f4 born to play rope to a5
check and exchange rooks rook the d4 by
Wesley we have b5 now rook to de
came to see to rope the g3 g5 Bishop to
d4 rook attacks Bishop and Bishop to e3
and now rook to d3 again if Bishop
captures then rook captures rook and
it's it's a winning position for white
rook the g2 check King b3 Bishop to c1
we have b6 now came to b6
rook to the rook to d4 rook checks King
goes to a for King to f5 we have Brooke
to be for offering a trade rook a to
check King Bingley 5 and now bishop cap
on f4 and here we have rook captures on
f4 King captures on f4 and b7 now here
something like
King King to g5 could be played I don't
know
I think after rook captures on f4 wesley
resigned the game because after king
captures you simply have b7 there's
really nothing you can do here
for example King captures you can't play
b8 just yet because of rook to be to
check but but simply came to b6 and
after rook to beat to check King to a7
and it's all over you will simply
promote this pawn after rook sacrifices
itself for it then you promote the a
pawn and it's all over
so quite quite a game derived from the
London system and quite an interesting
way to counter the London system it
doesn't seem like Wesley made any
mistakes or anything it was just it was
just a better play by Magnus Carlsen so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I will probably cover one
more game from this round probably
Medeiros win against Peter Svidler but I
don't know if I will be able to do it
today probably do it tomorrow morning so
yeah I do hope you enjoyed it thing as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon